عادةً ما يحاول المسؤولون عن جهاز المخابرات السرية في المملكة المتحدة
تجنب
أن يصبحوا مركز الاهتمام ، ولكن
حان الوقت الآن للتغيير ، وقد ألقى رئيس التجسس البريطاني
أول خطاب عام كبير له
منذ أن أصبح رئيسًا لـ mi6 وهذا هو
سبب حاجته إلى الدعم العام خاصة
من التكنولوجيا  صناعة
نفتح مشاكل مهمتنا
لأولئك الذين لديهم موهبة في المنظمات
التي لا تعمل عادةً مع
الأمن القومي
على عكس q في أفلام السندات ، لا يمكننا القيام
بكل ذلك داخليًا ،
ولا يمكنني التأكيد بما فيه الكفاية على ما هو تغيير البحر
هذا في ثقافة mi6
روح وطريقة
العمل ويقول إن الذكاء الاصطناعي
يمكن أن يحدث ثورة في الجغرافيا السياسية على
مدى العقد المقبل ، ومن
المرجح أن تحصل الدول القادرة على إتقانها أولاً على
اليد العليا لريتشارد مور ،
أحد أكبر التهديدات يأتي من
ضباط المخابرات الصينيين الذين يسعون
لاستغلال  الطبيعة المفتوحة لمجتمعنا
بما في ذلك من خلال استخدام
منصات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لتسهيل عملياتهم
نحن  بشأن محاولة الحكومة الصينية
تشويه
الخطاب العام واتخاذ القرارات السياسية
في جميع أنحاء العالم